pas mal vous avez vu une fille moi j'ai
une question à vous poser ce soir si
vous aviez quelque chose à vous faire
pardonner ou demander pardon à quelqu'un
dans quelque chose à vous faire
pardonner plus exactement ce serait à
qui à qui demanderiez-vous pardon c'est
Bernard
qui est un peu feignant
certains donnés
je pardonne à TF1 en fait de
attendez c'est très sérieux il y a
beaucoup d'émotions dans ma voix
quand même plus talentueux comme la
reconnue tout de même monsieur Mougeot
dans son bouquin qui était Président de
TF1 absolument et alors qu'est-ce que je
voulais dire je veux dire que je
pardonne cette erreur cette erreur
professionnelle de TF1 je ne leur en
veux pas du tout
bien sûr
ça me fait énormément de peine et quoi
qu'il en soit voilà je leur pardonne
m'avoir viré et finalement je les
remercie aussi
moi si vous me permettez vous êtes ici
chez vous en même temps
[Rires]
Bernard je te pardonne ta carrière
d'animateur télé
je te pardonne même des années de chiens
qui pètent en vidéo
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vidéo gag vous avez aimé ou
pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est toutes les fautes animées si ça
c'est bien
je ne pardonne jamais à naufrage
[Rires]
de l'Olympique de Marseille de m'avoir
écarté
ique de différence de vue stratégique tu
sais c'est la phrase
de m'avoir écarté au vu de du terrible
match d'hier soir
de la terrible humiliation que Marseille
a subi
de d'avoir endossé cette terrible la
responsabilité la responsabilité
médiatique uniquement je précise voilà
Géraldine à qui vous à qui vous
pardonnez je pardonne à Guillaume
j'entends oui alors Guillaume Jeanthon
je te pardonne sache que c'est
effroyable d'être à côté de toi
non mais franchement Pascal les fins
d'émission sont un calvaire à côté de
Guillaume Janton il faut savoir
à partir de 20h45 Guillaume Genton est
pris de de spasmes
il a les jambes qui tremblent il a des
sortes de bruit alors est-ce que tu peux
faire ce bruit en fait on a des bruits
il ne faut pas rire quand ce sont des
sujets extrêmement sérieux ah je ne sais
pas si c'est la pression c'est le côté
de votre mariage à l'enterrement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est une torture mais je le
pardonne parce que c'est un merveilleux
voisin malgré tout
[Applaudissements]
ça
c'est attention ce soir
c'est une personne c'est Michel Marie
les conseils
c'est complètement gratos mais dès que
Michel Marie arrive en fait c'est à
cause des imitations de Cyril c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
le problème
bien sûr
[Rires]
parce qu'on s'est appelé tous les textes
Géraldine on a parlé un peu des petits
nouveaux des chroniqueurs vous faites
partie
l'été habitué sur tout le monde
qu'est-ce que vous avez dit alors les
nouveaux
[Applaudissements]
la présentatrice du câble
pour moi vous êtes le numéro 1 parce que
tu fais du mal aux équipes
Géraldine évidemment
que chaque année je suis toujours en
conflit avec eux et que des impôts
fiscal non non je déclare tout il y a
aucun souci même mes enfants j'ai
déclare et donc voilà donc je vous
pardonne je vous pardonne de mes
conseils
petite moyenne grosse elle est comment
un peu comme une famille maintenant
vous avez de la chance exactement
mais moi je suis sûr Daniel je veux
jouer à un jeu moi je suis sûr qu'il y a
plein d'hommes qui vous kiffent
en tout cas
maintenant
vous savez quelque chose on se connaît
depuis 30 ans justement en fait alors
autour de cette table je pardonne à
Bernard Montier de nous faire baver tous
les soirs dans les loges avec sa vie de
Luc
[Musique]
sinoises excusez
alors non non mais disons que je ne
parle pas
répondu je ne parle pas de les voyages
parce que je voyage pas au téléphone
alors je ne voyage Pascal en ce moment
d'elle vous voulez proposer peut-être de
venir avec moi vous avez refusé pas ah
c'est vrai je me souviens pas
d'invitation
enfin c'est énervant ça me fait prendre
conscience il est incroyable parce qu'il
a dit son âge un jour je sais même pas
si on a le droit de le dire en plus 72
non mais c'est incroyable
je sais pas franchement
[Applaudissements]
j'ai 66 ans et quelques mois et voilà et
maintenant j'ai encore rien fait je
tiens à le dire parce qu'on me pose
souvent la question et je ne suis pas
bronzé c'est grâce à notre cher
maquilleuse et en plus quand tu lui dis
mais
la peau de brun donc c'est beaucoup plus
facile en deux minutes
Sophie Coste je vous pardonner Pascal ah
mince alors moi qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
que nous avons fait le le pilote pour
PAF donc nous nous sommes rencontrés on
se connaissait pas et je vous ai envoyé
un petit message mais oui sympathique
sur Instagram et vous m'avez mis en fait
le plus gros ventes
il m'a dit je t'ai envoyé un message sur
Instagram
et ça peut vexé tu vois j'étais un peu
compliqué
je suis désolé je suis désolé je vous
pardonne Kenny Kelly bonsoir Comment ça
va gagner un petit problème de veste
c'est canon
c'est génial c'est canon
c'est canon là
dehors elle est magnifique elle dit
comme toujours Kelly alors qui
pardonnerez-vous à qui voulait qui
pardonner c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué bah j'ai envie de pardonner
Bernard
je voulais dire que comme tout à l'heure
on s'en est parlé grâce à moi sur les
réseaux tu es devenu une star
il faut expliquer pourquoi alors parce
que j'ai été une de tes premières muses
avec qui tu as fait des millions de vues
et maintenant tu m'oublies un petit peu
tu en trouves d'autres
tu fais ton petit chemin je t'ai vu avec
Louane hier je t'ai vu avec d'autres et
parfois ça me brise le cœur voilà
je te trouve un petit peu opportuniste
comme un soufflé au fromage
peu dégoûté mais j'ai envie de te
pardonner parce que c'est le jour alors
je t'aime et je te pardonne
Bern
ARD vous lui avez brisé le cœur
suffit elle sait ce que je pense d'elle
mais non
je suis très attaché à Kelly
[Rires]
qui va arriver à 20h30 je pardonne de
m'avoir mis ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]